confidence needs evidence that's how you  feed it  in my generation I think we really  screwed this up because we had this huge  self-esteem movement and I remember  Elementary School junior high it's like  you know you just get told you're great  but what the science actually shows is  this is that we don't get that like  testosterone bump of like confidence  unless we've done something to earn it  how dare you you're gonna get canceled  for that statement Steve you know that  right probably probably it's so Central  to things because like we get told the  wrong idea so much and instead like we  need to do the work and it's not that  you have a certainty about it  but it's to know that hey I've prepared  like I put in the work I've been  consistent